c'est difficile de sentir l'odeur d'une
soupe quand on a la tête dans la soupe
cette citation est apparemment de
quelqu'un que ça ferait jane lynch et
chrysler mais je la trouve très
intéressante parce qu'elle arrive elle
quelque chose sur notre façon d'être en
général où on a envie de prendre un peu
de perspectives on a envie de prendre de
la hauteur
mais bien souvent on a tendance à rester
la tête dans le guidon le nez dans le
sac
et du coup c'est difficile ça c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler du coup son
billet ils sont bi laisser aller quand
ils sont d'ailleurs fatigué mais surtout
celle est qui ne se rend pas trop compte
de ce qu'il fait c'est celui qui sort
son téléphone s'en soit rendu compte
qu'ils se croque sur twitter à n'en plus
finir ce qu'ils soient et d'une
application à une autre
bref ces zombies les et le gros plein de
zombies les c'est que quand je débats
c'est souvent en ville et qui continue
par prendre les commandes
je flippe ar men est récent mais en tant
que jeu meilleur il sans réfléchir à
pourquoi est-ce que je m'énerve et quel
est l'intérêt de m'énerver
je me mets à énerver les autres sans me
rendre compte que je les énervés que ce
n'est pas très complices pas énervé et
que du coup ils vont sans doute moins
bien réfléchir ils ont bill et si
malheureusement le lait qui est aux
commandes
et du coup marie des résolutions pour du
grain c'est faire en sorte que son gilet
soit peut-être un peu moins aux
commandes ou en tout cas qu'il fasse un
peu moins de la merde quand il est aux
commandes
alors pour y arriver on pourrait se dire
que ma résolution c'est du boulot c'est
de réveiller autant que possible son
bilan et ça fait partie un peu du
problème mais en fait résolution aussi
valeureuses en a eu une chance de pas
être très efficaces à s4 uc dippach
commence à faire pendant une semaine
mais au bout de deux semaines
moi en tout cas on risque de juste
laisser traîner ça la difficulté des
bonnes résolutions cesser les tenir
mais finalement une bonne résolution qui
est difficile à tenir c'est ce qu'on
peut appeler une mauvaise bonnes
résolutions bonnes résolutions mais
juste trop difficile du coup l'an passé
mauvaise bonne résolution est plutôt
qu'avoir des mauvaises bonnes
résolutions bah j'ai un peu plus
réfléchi car manger une tension était
attirée sur une idée qui vient de la
communauté rationaliste et aux états
unis qui s'appelle le trigger a ction
plane une tape donc un tape c koi bas
trigger action peine ça veut dire que l
douarin trigger qu'un signal et on va
réagir on va se forcer à faire quelque
chose de si possible assez simple mais
on se force qu'elle va faire quelque
chose à chaque fois qu'on voit le signal
en question et j'ai commencé à faire un
tapez donc le tap que j'ai mis en place
à ces sept fois que je touche mon
téléphone ou un ordinateur
il faut que je me dise qu est ce que je
vais faire avec c'est pas dire que je
m'interdis de faire ce que je voulais
faire mais ça veut dire que au moins dès
que je touche ces objets je dois avoir
cette réaction me dire mais qu'est ce
que je suis en train de faire ou qu'est
ce que je prévois de faire et c'est
super efficace mais ça m'a fait vraiment
réfléchir à comment ce que j'utilise mon
téléphone en particulier ça a empêché
plus d'une fois
ça réveille un petit peu plus d'une fois
son bi les qui commençait à aller sur
twitter sans s'en rendre compte
et du coup vous pourriez croire que ma
bonne résolution pour 2020 c'est un
autre tape de ce genre en fait pas tout
à fait le problème c'est que si je
commence à réfléchir à zombie les l'est
en général
malheureusement il a énormément de bugs
les léa c'est très très très améliorable
et suffira pas de 1 ou 2 tapez pour que
il s'améliore vraiment suffisamment
du coup ma résolution pour 2020 en fait
c'est plus une méta résolution dans le
sens où c'est ma résolution c'est de
prendre plus régulièrement des
résolutions de chercher déjà plus
régulièrement à identifier les bugs
à chaque fois que j'arrive à identifier
un an de vyborg essayer de trouver un
taf à mettre en place pour pouvoir
corriger le bug et améliorer la
situation de zombies les où c'est
possible la réveiller
bref ma radiation pour 2001 s'est du
coup de mettre en place davantage de tap
cependant ça ça serait une mauvaise
bonne révolution puisque ça n'est pas un
tap
c'est un peu un objectif que je me donne
comme ça et ça c'est trop vague du coup
pour avoir une bonne bonne mais t'as
résolution pour 2020 bah je vais avoir
un tap qui va être un méta tape en fait
est le méta tape c'est que à chaque fois
que je sens un autre une fois quelque
chose d'un satisfaisants chez les
houches et son bill et je vais devoir
réfléchir à un tape à mettre en place
quand ça ne veut pas dire que je vais
vraiment mettre en place se tape mais au
moins je vais me forcer à réfléchir à
quelle table pour être efficace pour
résoudre tel inconfort qu'elle
insatisfaction tel bug que j'ai
découvert chez les hommes chez les
zombies les
en fait en particulier même avant de
mettre en place il faut réfléchir un
table ce que je vais faire c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'il ya une situation
d'inconfort
je vais penser à un moment où son bilan
a été réveillé et j'ai une idée de créer
un évènement ou zombies les se réveille
qui soit assez marquant
oui parce que au final j'aime bien cette
histoire de d'avoir la tête et dans la
soupe et de pouvoir la sentir donc je
vais mettre ça en pratique que mme et m
et dans la soupe dans ma agressé de
réveiller les mais aussi et surtout je
vais essayer de me souvenir de la
sensation de sortir la tête de la soupe